[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était la militante écologiste
suédoise Greta Thunberg qui s'est fait
connaître on sait bien sûr avec ses
prises de position tranchées ce qu'elle
a déclaré hier à propos de la conférence
de l'ONU sur le climat qui doit s'ouvrir
dimanche ce dimanche en Égypte les tout
autant Greta Thunberg crois que les cops
dans leur forme actuelle ne servent à
rien en fait ces grands rendez-vous
internationaux sont pour elle comme des
espèces d'écran de fumée j'en parle avec
Eddy Perez il est responsable de la
diplomatie climatique internationale au
Réseau Action Climat mais super bonsoir
et avec Patrick Bonnin il est
responsable de la campagne climat
énergie Greenpeace Canada monsieur
bonnet bonsoir alors je vais commencer
avec vous monsieur Perez on parle de
diplomatie avec vous alors c'est COP
dont celui de dimanche sont des hauts
lieux de diplomate internationale il
servent à quoi rappelez-moi à quoi ils
servent ces codes précisément alors il
faut penser à une COP comme un espace de
gouvernance ou le chef d'État et leur
représentants d'à peu près 200 pays se
rencontrent en fait pour décider les
orientations en matière de lutte au
changement climatique à l'échelle
globale la rencontre se passe chaque
année dans un pays différent chaque
année depuis 1995 ça fait un bout de
temps exactement et donc c'est ça c'est
aussi un espace de pouvoir où il y a les
élites il y a aussi des gens qui vont
là-bas pour représenter leurs intérêts
et besoins en matière de lutte au
changement climatique donc ces grands
décideurs décident de la marche à suivre
et puis ce ce comment dire
s'auto-évaluer les uns les autres ou si
on est censé fournir ce qu'on a fait en
matière de réduction les cibles est-ce
qu'on les a plus ou moins atteintes tout
ça ça se passe ça aussi
c'est un espace où les pays sont
attendus avec des plans climatiques et
dans le cadre par exemple de l'accord de
Paris chaque 5 ans un pays comme le
Canada doit présenter ses ambitions en
matière de changement climatique bon ce
badin je sais pas si vous avez déjà
assisté à une en tant que à plusieurs
Coop ce qu'il faut dire aussi de ces
conférences qu'on peut déplorer en tout
cas c'est tout ce qu'on se fixe comme
objectif ne sont il y a rien de
contraignant là-dedans n'est-ce pas ce
que je me trompe pas en fait on parle de
l'accord de Paris c'est conférence là
vise entre autres à faire le point à
faire avancer les pays et leurs
engagements qu'ils ont pris à travers
l'accord de Paris en effet l'accord de
Paris a été signé et c'est impossible à
l'époque en 2015 d'avoir une entente
contraignante entre autres les
États-Unis n'auraient pas embarqué donc
ce n'est pas une entente parfaite par
contre elle force les pays à revenir à
la table de négociation dans le cadre de
ces conférences là à chaque année et à
montrer avec une réédition de compte
transparente quels sont leurs objectifs
quels sont les plans qu'ils ont en place
quel est le financement qu'ils ont mis
sur la table pour les pays en
développement et malheureusement en
effet le compte n'y est pas actuellement
on se dirige par exemple vers un
réchauffement d'environ 2,6 degrés
Celsius alors que l'accord de Paris vise
un point 5 degrés Celsius et ce qui
m'amène à Monsieur goutterest
j'oublie son titre exact à l'ONU
c'est le grand secrétaire général de
l'ONU qui a dit c'est que c'était fait à
toute fin utile de de
l'écho-blanchement que tout ce qu'on
fait au fait semblant de faire parce
qu'on est encore à ce niveau là qu'on
peut pas atteindre les objectifs qu'on
s'est fixé à Paris au rythme on y va en
ce moment peut-être que il faut
réfléchir qui veut une COP qui veut
assister à la coque et jusqu'à
maintenant je pense aux États les plus
vulnérables pour le changement
climatique par exemple les États
insulaires ils veulent participer à la
Coop demande en fait qu'au moment de
responsabilisation annuellement et lieu
parce que les conséquences des
changements climatique qui vivent sont
désastreuses d'un point de vue
économique et social donc pour eux n'est
pas aller en Cope c'est pas une option
c'est impossible parce que c'est leur
seul moment où ils peuvent regarder en
fait le ministre Guilbaud et lui dire
vous savez ce vous faites avec les
tonnes de CO2 que vous émettez dans
l'atmosphère à une conséquence sur nos
infrastructures sur nos vies ouais donc
c'est un rappel à l'ordre par les pays
les plus frappés immédiatement par le
changement climatique parce qu'on ne
doute pas qu'on sera tous éprouvés à un
moment ou un autre et qu'on l'est déjà
mais cela dit quand un Greta belge qui a
l'impression elle que c'est de l'éco
blanchiment que c'est ce sont des écrans
de fumée ces codes là et que tu as des
activistes de plus en plus militants je
voyais en France en fin de semaine des
militants qui coupaient des tuyaux d'eau
de bassin d'eau récoltés par les
agriculteurs qui ont subi la sécheresse
cet été on voit des gens qui occupent le
terminal d'Anne bridge la semaine
dernière
jusqu'où ça va aller il va est-ce que il
risque pas d'y avoir devant l'impression
qu'on a que les choses n'avancent pas
assez vite jusqu'à ce que le secrétaire
général de l'ONU lui-même le disent
est-ce qu'on ne risque pas d'avoir de
plus en plus de colère des cours anxiété
mais de colère aussi monsieur bonnet je
crois qu'il y pas un effet de plus en
plus de ces gestes d'éclats avec raison
parce qu'on le voit la trajectoire
actuelle elle nous mène vers un monde
invivable ou presque lorsqu'on parle de
2,6 degrés Celsius par contre ce genre
d'activité de manifestation de d'action
oui il y en aura plus mais il faut
également ce genre d'instance
internationale ou l'ensemble des pays se
réunissent pour régler cette
problématique qui est mondiale et les
cops les conférences des Nations Unies
permettent entre autres au pays les plus
vulnérables et dans ce cas-ci ça va se
passer en Afrique d'avoir voix au
chapitre ça se passe au niveau
consensuel les Nations Unies et les cops
l'accord de Paris a permis par exemple
d'inscrire la limite d'un point 5 degrés
Celsius qui est essentiel pour les
nations les plus menacées a permis de
faire avancer le financement de 100
milliards par année pour les pays en
développement dont ils ont besoin de la
part des pays développés c'est de l'aide
pour s'adapter au changement climatique
pour réduire leurs émissions et cette
année un enjeu majeur on appelle cela
perte et dommage donc des pays pensés au
Pakistan par exemple des pays ne sont
pas responsables du gros des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre mais qui
subissent déjà des pertes économiques
sociales humaines
depuis presque 30 ans que les pays
développés financent que les grands
polluants financent et paix pour les
dégâts parce que ces pays-là les plus
vulnérables ne sont pas responsables
mais cette coupe là ce sera un des
enjeux central et sans ce genre
d'instance internationale je ne vois pas
comment on peut arriver aussi à régler
la crise climatique mais ça n'empêche
rien à l'action nationale domestique sur
le terrain aux mobilisation a poussé les
gouvernements mais il faut s'entendre au
niveau international
et puis en plus vous avez parlé de Lula
il y a quelques minutes c'est le reflet
même d'une COP comme un espace de
pouvoir évidemment bolsonaro pendant
pendant quatre ans
à démoniser les cops comme des espaces
qui ne représentaient pas les intérêts
économiques propriétaire privé qu'il
voulait défendre et du moment où il y a
eu un changement de pouvoir ça a
complètement permis à ce pays-là de se
mettre de l'avant et d'être beaucoup
plus responsable face à ces changements
climatiques et donc il y a quand même un
élément de pouvoir et une dynamique
aussi qui se passe à l'échelle
domestique et qu'il faut tenir en
considération oui c'est ce que j'allais
vous dire parce que bon donc vous avez
bien établi que c'est comme on leur
utilité ne serait-ce que pour que
les leaders du monde se rendent bien
compte des problèmes des autres leaders
aussi mais il faut de la place aussi
pour la société civile il faut une lutte
il faut un combat Greta Thunberg parlait
d'éveiller les consciences est-ce que
dans les cops il y a suffisamment de
place pour la société civile vous me
disiez en entrée de jeu qu'il y en avait
mais quand on pense à l'Égypte
apparemment il y en aura pas beaucoup à
la prochaine cap monsieur bonnet il y a
des enjeux majeurs en effet au niveau
des droits humains évidemment on peut
pas avoir de justice climatique sans
justice sociale et l'Egypte assez défi
énorme par contre au de la société
civile qui est présente dans ce genre de
Cope là en effet l'espace est trop
restreint il est aussi trop restreint
pour les groupes marginalisés pour les
femmes pour les autochtones ou si c'est
difficile d'avoir accès pour les pays du
Sud donc en termes de facilité d'aller
juste sur place de moins financiers
évidemment les pays développés sont plus
représentés alors qu'ils sont
responsables de la crise climatique en
grande partie et ne sont ceux
essentiellement qui n'ont pas respecté
leur engagement en termes de réduction
de gaz à effet de serre en termes de
financement au pays en développement
donc évidemment ce genre de conférence
là pour nous elle est essentielle mais
pour les pays du Sud et les crucial oui
peut-être là-dessus les cops en soi
c'est pas une coupe du monde c'est pas
un festival une foire d'énergie
renouvelable c'est un espace de
gouvernance et ça a toujours été avec
ces défis d'exclusion l'année passée moi
j'ai participé au Coop depuis 2016 et de
j'ai toujours vu à quel point ce sont
des espaces qui qui marginalisent des
groupes à l'échelle mondiale cette année
évidemment c'est un contexte hyper
complexe en Égypte mais l'année passée
avec la covid le taux d'exclusion des
participants des pays dans le sud
extrêmement élevé il y a une COP par
exemple au Chili qui n'a même pas eu
lieu dans le pays a eu lieu à Madrid et
donc il y a toujours ce contexte là
parce que les coques c'est le reflet de
l'injustice sociale et climatique
également alors donc est-ce qu'ils sont
perfectés est-ce qu'on peut envisager un
avenir proche d'abord où ce serait aussi
plus efficace plus efficient où on
arriverait à quelque chose de plus
contraignant et où la société civile
aurait plus de place est-ce que ça se
discute
quand même beaucoup je peux vous dire
par exemple en ce moment une grande
discussion c'est comment est-ce qu'on
fait sortir les grands pollueurs de ces
espaces là parce que il se faufile même
l'année passée là même si la ville de
Glasgow s'il y avait des acteurs de haut
niveau qui demandaient aux pollueurs de
ne pas venir dans des conférences
climatiques ils ont essayé à trouver des
badges d'un peu partout de différentes
organisations donc on se trouvait avec
la plus grande délégation à la COP 26
qui était des grands pollueurs et donc
aujourd'hui la grande demande qu'on fait
aux Nations Unies c'est de faire sortir
en fait ces conflits d'intérêts profonds
à l'intérieur de ces espaces là et c'est
un débat actuel qu'on a à la cop27
nécessairement en sortant les
représentants les lobbies de l'industrie
qu'on qu'on enlève ce conflit la terre
est là parce que il y a les États qui
représentent carrément c'est c'est
certain qu'on enlève une épine du pied
des lorsqu'on parle par exemple de coke
qui est reconnu comme le plus grand
pollueur plastique au monde selon
plusieurs outils qui est à 99% sa
production de bouteilles c'est à partir
des énergies fossiles qui commanditent
la conférence c'est un peu comme un
marchand d'arbres ou fabricant d'armes
qui commandait une conférence sur la
paix ça n'a pas lieu d'être ils ont des
accès privilégiés évidemment on décida
vont influencer donc ils font enlever ce
lobbying et laisser justement les
négociations entre pays mais au-delà de
ça et en fondamentage de la part des
pays absolument il faut des cops mais il
faut les améliorer merci beaucoup
Monsieur Bonhomme monsieur Perez merci
beaucoup d'avoir participé à la
discussion
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI